[Applaudissements]
bon ben ça fait super plaisir de table
un dioula bété de la saison alors comme
on l'a dit avec benjamin dernière fois
cette saison mercredi ça tu l'as vue
politique le lundi c'est tu l'as vu
spécial télé alors j'ai tu as fais à
fond pour trouver les meilleurs moments
télé de la semaine si vous les avez
ratés alors pas de souci petite session
rattrapage dans le site dans le 360 et
les nouvelles séquences
dans tout le monde veut prendre sa place
j'ai trouvé le candidat qui parle comme
benjamin castaldi et qui fait genre y
connaissait la réponse en plus forte et
séries télévisées
lille est gaby bree et susan sont elles
voisinent sur wisteria lane cachent des
vapeurs airways j'ai rien en dehors des
respects 15 août comme ça toi alors
c'est des
réseaux comme ça fait beaucoup desperate
housewives voilà c'est ça la vraie bon
j'ai maté au coeur d'une enquête sur ces
stars et en général quand tu tentes ce
genre de vannes pendant test
d'alcoolémie sait qu'il sera sûrement
positif
en cuisine j'ai découvert stephen ans
restaurateur qui essaie d'y aller je
vais détendre l'atmosphère avec le chef
ces deux jours ouais ça passe bien scar
within d'où viennent du congé m
on reste dans le thème cuisine avec
masterchef avec des recettes qui met
l'eau à la bouche jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit goûté par les candidats
deux passions aux agrumes et est gérée
mètres met en corner à l'intérieur ça va
me raymond ferrier mesure
c'est dégueulasse
et puis cette semaine c'était la rentrée
des classes alors forcément la france
info s'est rendu sur place vous êtes
contente de revenir à l'école car ça
faisait longtemps qu'on l'aimé bon
c'était sans compter sur enthousiasme de
cette petite fille à l'idée de retrouver
ses copains parce que gilles galud
mathématiques et pour voir tes copines
aussi
on est pour voir ses copines aussi ouais
et enfin dans des chiffres et des
lettres même après deux mois de vacances
s'ils perdent pas le nord et gardent le
sens des priorités les coquinous
commis à karine 8 oui irection c'est un
temps calme qui a trouvé si je peux dire
le mot le plus long
parce qu on est lundi je me suis dit que
ça vous plairait de voir quelques
petites paires de fesses dès lundi alors
j'ai regardé tout nu et tout bronzé sur
tf6 une émission qualité sur les
vacances des naturistes et franchement
vous avez pas déçu attend bien
bah ouais parce qu'on a découvert pascal
qui tient une boutique dans un village à
100 % nature et c'est une idée de chez
vous pour faire péter son business
puisqu'il a décidé de vendre des
vêtements très bas à sa gauche mais
heureusement il ya d'autres articles
comme des grilles de loto bien
incroyable
mais s'ils regardent alors 30
non non non non on a eu bon dieu on ne
dit pas que santa fe 2 millions non non
on a eu deux ans
heureusement que pascal était là pour
nous faire découvrir les spécialités de
la région du disque sas et le pastis
qu'il faut goûter à tout prix et je veux
le mettre avec
l'apéro gratte cul et l'apéro des culs
nus a dit que c'est une jeune nature il
a décidé de faire découvrir à son mec
les vacances à voile apparemment by ça
veut dire ils avaient l'air de bien qui
fait pas de prise de tête en fait c'est
très simple les choses sont toutes les
choses sont plus simples tu m'étonnes
mais mon naturiste préféré ça reste
solide et qui sait profiter des petits
plaisirs de la vie au label
olivier au top de sa forme même pendant
une séance de sport pas toujours
évidente pourtant quand on est naturiste
4 le problème c'est que les couilles le
savent pas si elles manquent de rien
devant toi
vous le savez chacun y introduira la
météo des réseaux vous adorez alors je
me suis dit pourquoi pas finir aussi
avec une petite touche réseaux sociaux
lundi aussi tous les jours les français
laissent des milliers de commentaires et
d'avis sur internet alors je me suis dit
pourquoi pas vous les montrer c'est la
première de la vie des français
et oui dans la vie des français on
commence au commissariat où ce gars
attribué cinq étoiles car la garde à vue
était plutôt sympathique une inscription
au total correct et dans le respect est
franchement rien à redire mais j'y
reviendrais pas pour autant butt si
toutes les gardes à vue pouvait être
comme ça ce matin moi mais en tout cas
il y en un qui est moins content c'est
ce client d'un site de vente en ligne
qui a acheté une bombe au point mort
priori défectueuse je l'essayé lors d'un
barbecue très difficile à répartir sur
la viande la pression est trop forte et
le goût trop acide je recommande à cet
article c'est plus simple d'utiliser un
moulin à poivre la région reste qu'au
moulin à poivre et direction le bureau
de poste où cette maman est un peu
mécontent du service car le personnel
est agréable le temps d'attenté est
extrêmement long voir la photo mon fils
ça bien qu'étant allez un petit tour au
cinéma mais c'était sans compter sur cet
avis très déçu à ses anciennes dernière
gap était pandas sont celles que la mort
pendant tout petit comme quoi même dans
une salle de ciné faites gaffe à ce qui
est un casse tête s'ils ont voyagé un
peu direction l'italie devant la tour
depuis ce qui fait pas l'unanimité parce
qu'apparemment la tour penchée et on
finit en france sur les falaises du cap
blanc nez ou quant à adorer la très
belle vue attention cependant aux veaux
piolenc notre petite chienne s'est
envolé
les aléas du direct c'est bien
vous avez les cuma vous
[Applaudissements]
un recours avait remercié
merci à tous